quand on regarde trop d'écran quand on
est petit qu'est-ce qui se passe
on a mal aux yeux tu as tout à fait
raison qu'est-ce qui se passe d'autre
cerveau il comprend rien exactement
parce que votre cerveau il y a beaucoup
d'images beaucoup de choses dans la tête
et au bout d'un moment il comprend plus
bien ce qui se passe il arrive plus bien
à retenir les choses
[Musique]
je suis Caroline janvier député
renaissance de la deuxième
circonscription du Loiret et je
travaille sur la surexposition aux
écrans des enfants les enfants passent
en moyenne pour les 0 2 ans 3 heures et
11 minutes par jour devant un écran et
c'est un effet sur les apprentissages
scolaires notamment donc voilà c'est mon
combat
[Musique]
ce jour là à Orléans dans une école
maternelle de sa circonscription
Caroline janvier assiste à une séance de
sensibilisation aux écrans
là moi je vous ai mis des affiches avec
des situations avec une famille qui
utilise beaucoup les écrans est-ce qu'il
se parle entre eux et ce qu'ils font des
choses ensemble et les plus petits font
quoi parce que lui là
il s'endort en plus c'est peut-être pas
adapté son âge quand il comprend pas
ça se trouve en plus il devrait être au
lit
parfois je regarde un film d'horreur et
après tu fais des cauchemars
des élèves de 5 ans déjà régulièrement
exposé non seulement à la télévision
mais aussi au tablettes au smartphone
quand on les interroge on se rend compte
que c'est très présent c'est devenu
anodin
anodin enfin c'est des écrans bah oui ça
fait partie de la vie ça se passe dans
quelle pièce et les conséquences de
cette exposition cet enseignante les
repères immédiatement on a constaté
c'était au niveau de la concentration de
la tension de la disponibilité lors
d'une activité qui est très très courte
et
on relit ça justement à l'exposition des
écrans qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire tu
fais des colères parfois
quand on est à la télé oui
Caroline janvier porte une proposition
de loi pour limiter ces temps d'écran et
ce n'est pas pour rien si elle s'adresse
avant tout au plus jeune plus vous êtes
à un utilisateur précoce de ces de ces
équipements-là plus vous serez un
utilisateur compulsif ou en tout cas
important donc évidemment quand à
l'école on peut avoir des instituteurs
qui parlent de ça qui éduquent aussi aux
bonnes usages et aux pas trop d'usage ça
change tout
[Musique]
et en primaire cela se confirme
à 10 ans aucun de ses élèves de CM2
n'échappe aux écrans et reconnaît même
avoir du mal à s'en passer
donc la question c'est doit-on limiter
les écrans
de tout faire pour ne pas enfin
s'éloigner le poser un endroit et aller
faire autre chose dans une autre pièce
ce que des fois c'est simplement en le
regardant tu as envie d'y jouer tu
restes comme ça c'est comme la
nourriture tu peux pas dès que tu le
vois tu as envie moi ça m'est arrivé une
fois j'étais en appel avec mes copines
et en jouer à un jeu vidéo et on a joué
trop longtemps et combien de temps tu
sais
2h ça agit presque comme une drogue en
fait finalement voilà c'est quand on
parle d'addiction on parle de différents
types de drogues puis bon on se rend
compte que finalement les écrans ça a le
même effet c'est une lutte à mener au
quotidien au quotidien à travers les
activités qu'on met en place notamment
faire revenir la lecture au centre des
intérêts des activités sportives les
activités dans la nature c'est autant
d'outils qui vont les aider à lutter
justement contre l'addiction aux écrans
alors
on n'a pas de formation particulière
pour ça mais en tout cas on sait que
c'est notre rôle
on sait qu'on a un acteur principal en
tout cas sur sur ce type de lutte
en réalité une prévention qui dépend
trop souvent du bon vouloir des écoles
des professeurs et que Caroline janvier
souhaite rendre systématique
c'est justement ce que prévoit la loi
que je porte c'est une formation de tous
les enseignants du premier degré pour
que tout le monde soit sensibilisé et
soit équipé d'outils pour et bien faire
comprendre aussi aux enfants à
l'importance de et les risques d'une
surexposition aux écrans je me vote pour
je vous remercie au revoir
[Musique]
la députée veut même aller plus loin
former les professionnels de la petite
enfance les professionnels de santé
aussi bonjour car une exposition précoce
peut entraîner des troubles graves du
développement de l'enfant on y va allez
viens vas-y on y va
cette pédiatre a une consultation unique
en France à l'hôpital sur la
surexposition aux écrans
à trois ans Maya ne parle quasiment pas
ça a commencé vers quel âge vous diriez
à peu près là vous dites trois mois six
mois elle était vraiment devant la télé
est-ce que c'est allumé pendant les
repas est-ce que vous mangez avec oui
est-ce que vous l'utilisez pour la
calmer oui elle a un examen pour moi
tout à fait le médecin s'appuie sur un
questionnaire spécifique pour évaluer sa
consommation et sa dépendance aux écrans
résultat 5 à 6 heures par jour
ça impacte vraiment de nombreux domaines
que ça soit le comportement la gestion
de des humeurs la gestion des
frustrations qui est importante quand on
est petit et surtout l'apprentissage est
l'entrée dans le langage et dans les
interactions ouais tu veux faire le
docteur
des enfants sans langage cohérent qui
comme Maya ne font que répéter ce qu'ils
ont vu dans les dessins animés
effectivement les différentes
applications YouTube ou ce que vous
voulez ont tendance à mettre l'alphabet
en faisant croire un peu aux parents que
c'est comme ça qu'on va faire des
progrès et du coup on met les choses à
l'envers c'est à dire qu'on apprend
l'alphabet à 3 ans mais on ne parle pas
encore bien à 3 ans et en fait moi ce
que je veux c'est que votre petite fille
elle apprenne le mot pull le mot
chaussettes le mot pomme le mot camion
les mots du quotidien et c'est sur ça
qu'il va falloir revenir beaucoup
beaucoup pour que le langage s'installe
et pour cela le message de la pédiatre
est radical arrêt total des écrans
de jouer ben c'est pas du tout pareil
parce que l'enfant il regarde et du coup
ça interrompre ses capacité et là d'être
dehors et de marcher
en poussette de marché et de regarder le
monde qui l'entoure c'est important et
se calmer plutôt avec un livre plutôt
que avec l'écran le soir
Maya a éteint les écrans il y a 4 mois
un sevrage difficile
maintenant faut tenir bon demander à la
famille de faire pareil parce qu'elle
est en train de progresser votre petite
fille je trouve aussi au vu de votre
histoire mais le chemin est un peu long
comme on disait ça prend du temps
le lendemain Caroline janvier retrouve
le docteur diosica à son cabinet bonjour
bonjour
elle a fait partie de ceux qui ont
alerté la député sur les ravages des
écrans
Riley 4 ans et sa maman consulte la
pédiatre depuis quelques mois
Jennifer a eu un déclic le jour où son
fils est entré en maternelle et là je me
suis vraiment rendue compte qu'il y
avait un énorme décalage avec les autres
enfants ne parlait pas du tout
il savait pas jouer il s'exprime avec
des cris enfin c'était il était vraiment
à l'opposé des autres enfants vous
imaginez madame
[Musique]
pas du tout sinon j'aurais jamais donné
à mon enfant pas du tout franchement si
c'était à refaire je le referai et
est-ce que vous trouvez que on est pas
suffisamment informé des choses est-ce
que vous auriez aimé le savoir
et comment comment vous auriez aimé
qu'on vous le dise ça la maternité c'est
la maternité vous pensez qu'on devrait
dire attention apparemment c'est dans le
carnet de santé mais je vais avouer que
je l'ai pas lu mais au début d'accord
donc vous en fait vous avez découvert ce
problème là en voyant ce que ça crée
chez votre enfant et en travaillant avec
le pédiatre là il commence à s'en sortir
avec la motricité fine tiens bien ton
style oui ça y est parce que Caroline
janvier propose d'alerter dès la
grossesse sur le danger des écrans
moi ce que je me dis c'est qu'il faut
que nous on protège mieux vos enfants on
vous informe mieux et qu'il faut qu'on
trouve les bons endroits pour vous
informer est-ce que c'est la maternité
c'est l'école c'est des campagnes
d'information
et comme pour l'école il faut former les
professionnels de santé les externes les
internes que je vois à l'hôpital ne sont
pas du tout formés ils doivent avoir de
la médecine sociale qui est extrêmement
faible dans leur temps de travail de
dans le programme les médecins
généralistes sont encore moins formés et
je répète que 80% des enfants en France
ont suivi par les médecins généralistes
bref actuellement le temps de formation
sur les écrans il est égal à 0 quasiment
donc c'est si on veut bien se poser des
questions si on veut bien se dire tiens
tiens nous vivons dans un autre monde
qui n'a plus rien à voir depuis
maintenant quelques années peut-être que
l'enfant est impacté par ce par ce
problème
un monde où l'écran est omniprésent même
là où on ne s'y attend pas
quand on voit qu'on a maintenant par
exemple des constructeurs de Landau de
poussette qui prévoit des petits inserts
ou vous avez juste à mettre votre votre
tablette ou votre écran pour que le bébé
soit surtout exposé en permanence on
voit bien qu'il y a un problème merci
Madame merci à vous tous Voilà et puis
effectivement on a besoin de vous pour
convaincre les autres parents vont
continuer et pas de souci
mais justement comment convaincre ses
parents qui passent à travers tous les
filtres
ceux qui ne fréquentent pas les
structures de la petite enfance ce qui
ne voit que peu le médecin
ce soir là Caroline janvier organise un
temps d'échange et de sensibilisation
aux écrans avec des habitants de sa
circonscription
les risques de troupes primaires du
langage peuvent être multipliés par 6 en
cas d'une exposition trop importante et
vous le savez sans doute un enfant qui a
des troubles du langage et bien ça va le
mettre en difficulté dans tous ces
apprentissages
la député leur soumet l'une de ces
mesures phares imposer un avertissement
sur les emballages de téléphone tablette
ou ordinateur pour informer des risques
d'une surexposition
on sait que je parle j'avouerais que
c'est peut-être le point pour lequel
j'ai eu plus de difficultés parce qu'il
y a évidemment un peu un bras de fer
avec les industriels qui nous dit mais
non il y a pas besoin les gens lisent
pas je leur dis bah si dans ce cas là ça
va pas vous mettre en difficulté
faisons-le voilà
je sais que là vous avez quand même
entamé
une croisette qui ne sera peut-être pas
facile pour moi le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en réalité on a
minimisé les dangers d'une surexposition
aux écrans et moi je fais parfois le
parallèle ce qui s'est passé dans les
années 80 avec l'industrie du tabac où
vous aviez et bien les les industriels
qui
introduisaient le doute sur l'impact de
la consommation de tabac sur la santé
qui disait oui on n'est pas vraiment sûr
finalement il y a d'autres effets qui
interagissent et tout ça en fait il y a
un vrai sujet dont soit de
méconnaissance totale soit de
sous-évaluation du danger je vous invite
à suivre voilà les travaux qui vont
suivre et puis les actions qui vont être
mises en oeuvre je l'espère dans alors
Caroline janvier compte sur une prise de
conscience collective et oui c'est un
sujet il faut il faut s'en saisir merci
à tous
je crois qu'il y avait un consensus là
sur le fait qu'il y a une information
qui est très inégale très inégale et que
on a quelques lanceurs d'alerte quelque
part en assez connaisseurs du sujet mais
que malheureusement le doute
profite à la surexposition il faut
réguler ça et dire que la santé prime
sur l'intérieur économique
[Musique]
et 10 jours plus tard en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
l'exposition des enfants de moins de 3
ans est un poison pour eux c'est
dangereux pour des écrans à des impacts
sur la santé des enfants nous soyons
d'accord l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
les députés ont adopté à l'unanimité la
proposition de loi de Caroline janvier
[Musique]